Speaker 1: Yesterday, we had a nearly
14 hour livestream of the second day of
Joe Biden's Supreme Court nominee,
Judge Kaitano G. Brown Jackson's
confirmation hearing, during which she was asked
about 30 minutes of questions by each of the full
group, is twenty two senators on the Judiciary
Committee. I believe they got to 20 and then
the last two were going to go this morning and
we're going to get to some clips of what was asked
and we're going to talk about all of that. But
before doing any of that, I think it's important
to take an objective look at how qualified
Judge Jackson is and by any any, any measure,
any objective measure. Judge Katju Brown Jackson
is, or would be one of the most qualified Supreme
Court justices in recent history. And this is
not going by vague, ideology based opinions
or anything subjective merely looking at the
facts of her experience. It is hard to find a
more qualified Supreme Court justice recently
now. I know many of you, as we get into this,
are going to say, Wait, hold on a second,
David. If Amy Coney Barrett can be on the court,
if Kavanaugh can be on the court, why is this
even a conversation? And of course, you would be
completely correct to frame it in those terms. But
because it is worth actually thinking about the
experience of a potential Supreme Court justice.
We're going to look at it and there's a very good
chart out which looks at the risks the current
justices and compares Judge Jackson's experience.
And what you find when you look at it is that
she checks more boxes than do any of the justices
currently on the court. When you look at whether
she went to an Ivy League law school, which I
don't think is the the standard by which we should
evaluate qualifications, but one of the things
that many say is, well, where where was the legal
education? All of the justices currently on the
court other than Barrett, went to an Ivy League
law school, and so did Judge Jackson. When you
look at which justices were clerks on the Supreme
Court, Clarence Thomas, Alito and Sotomayor were
not. The other justices on the court were. And
Judge Jackson was a Supreme Court clerk, great
in terms of who was a public defender. None of
them. None of them. Judge Jackson actually brings
unique experience or would bring unique experience
to the court by virtue of having been a public
defender. None of the nine current justices did
that as a job. Only Justice Breyer, who would be
replaced by Judge Jackson, was on a sentencing
commission and indeed Judge Clayton G. Brown
Jackson was on a sentencing commission. Only
Judge Sotomayor of the justices currently on
the court was a district judge. Judge Jackson
has that experience in her background as well,
and currently all justices other than Elena Kagan
were judges on courts of appeals. And indeed,
Judge Jackson was a judge on the Court of Appeals.
Now I so so the objective case is as or more
qualified than any of the justices currently on
the court. Now, I think there's one interesting
thing to talk about here. You and I might look
at the experience of Judge Jackson and say,
Wow, that's that's amazing. And it's actually
fascinating that public defender experience
and sentencing commission experience and district
judge experience, that's unique. That's a unique
level of experience. Nobody on the court right
now has had experience in those three areas. But
there's a liability that comes with that, which
we learned about yesterday during the hearing.
And it is that it provides a significant amount
of fodder for which she can be attacked. Well,
why did you do this specific sentence in this
case or why did you rule in this particular way?
Why did you defend this particular client, even
though lawyers defend clients? That's what they
do. And the analogy here would be Imagine that
I ran for something you and I might say, Well,
you know, what's? What's great is I have over 10
years of talking about so many different issues.
You can just kind of look up and see what my
thoughts are. But the truth is that if you did,
let's call it a political colonoscopy or, you
know, a political body cavity search and you went
through everything I've ever said on the show, you
know, hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of hours,
you would without a doubt be able to find
things that don't represent number one.
What I would call the best of my show, that might
be opinions which have changed because. Is either
my opinions have changed or there's different
information that has now come out, which has
led me to have to revise opinions. So without
a doubt, if I were to run for something,
although I see it as a positive thing that I have
this long track record of people being able to see
the evolution of my views. You would be able to
troll that and find things to take out of context
or isolate that I without a doubt would make
me look bad. I'm I. It would make me look bad.
And along the same way, although you and I
might say wow, public defender experience
and sentencing commission experience and
district judge experience, that's unbelievable.
What we saw yesterday during the first day of
questions asked to Judge Jackson and what we
are already seeing today during the second day of
questions, which is underway right now is we are,
as we are recording today's show, is that it also
can serve as. A sort of catalyst or as a basis to
focus an extraordinarily narrowly on particular
decisions and take them out of context and and
whatever else. One other thing. There was a lot of
concern yesterday from Republican senators about
sentences given by Judge Jackson on what? Now
I want to be clear some people call it child
porn. I don't think that's the right word because
pornography is almost always legal and involving
consenting adults and is a business to some
degree, to just put child on that and to pretend
what we're talking about is child exploitation,
right? I mean, we're not talking about filmmakers
when we talk about people producing or whatever
these images, but for what they call child porn,
which I don't think is the right term for it. They
talked a lot about her departures from the maximum
penalties as sort of a liability. But the truth
is the people doing that like, for example,
Republican Senator Josh Hawley. He has previously
supported many judicial candidates that departed
from the maximum, sentencing numerous times.
So they focused in on that. But significant
hypocrisy there. So that's the qualifications.
Let's now go to some of the questioning.